jamais vesoul n'avait connu pareille
agitation pour un procès celui de
johnatan d'aval n'en est qu'à ses
prémices mais il est déjà hors norme à
plus d'un titre
à commencer par la place qu'il occupe
dans les médias on voit la place du
palais de vesoul qui est mobilisé par
les journalistes on voit 70 crs qui
investissent la ville pour protéger
alors on est en confinement en plan
vigipirate etc
mais effectivement oui c'est une
mobilisation c'est assez peu banale sur
vesoul à trouver de la place pour tout
le monde pour les jurés pour les
journalistes
tout se passe plutôt bien pour l'instant
ensuite le déroulé du procès ça c'est
autre chose
trois ans désormais que la france
entière se questionne au sujet du
meurtre d'alexia pourquoi comment cette
affaire at elle pu connaître un tel
retentissement pour ces journalistes
c'est d'abord le mensonge de l'accusé
qui en est à l'origine
qu'on a envie de savoir qui est cet
homme qui nous a fait pleurer avec lui
qui nous a trompés il ya presque une
envie de revanche alors ça c'est la part
de l'opinion et du coup la médiatisation
qui va avec c'est à dire que tout le
monde a envie de savoir qui est derrière
cet homme au double visage s'ils avaient
appelé la police ou la gendarmerie
immédiatement après on n'en serait pas
là
d'abord il encourait pas la même peine
ça aurait été un crime passionnel entre
guillemets et je pense qu'ils auraient
trois journalistes qui se battrait en
duel sur le banc d'après ces on ne
serait pas dans cette situation un
procès très médiatisé tout comme l'
enquête qui l'a précédée des mois durant
lesquels les proches d'alexis ans
longuement partager leur douleur
c'est un vrai choix à s'exprimer en
avant se permet de donner des éléments
de donner son point de vue
est ce que m'a expliqué la maman
d'alexia quand je les rencontre et c'est
que pour elle c'était important de
parler de sa fille d'abord pour qu'on
n'oublie pas et ensuite devant la donner
son propre point de vue et expliquer qui
était sa fille selon elle la sphère
d'aval devrait livrer son verdict ce
vendredi après avoir tenu en haleine la
presse judiciaire pendant plus de trois
ans